# Io sento il cuore a mille.
# Sento il cuore a mille.
# Mille.
Als wir damit anfingen,
die Sneakerness zu organisieren,
war es ein Get-together
all dieser Sneakerheads.
Mittlerweile kommen aber auch
Interessierte, um zu sehen,
was diese Sneakerheads
eben so machen
und warum sie zigtausende Franken
für Sneakers ausgeben.
# Willkomme i dr Schiinwält!
# Hier isch alles so nice!
Überall! 1'000 Menschen.
Die hat er vorhin gemeint, oder?
- Die gibt es nur zehnmal.
Das ist derjenige, den Travis
gekauft hat - für 35'000 Fr.
Unglaublich!
Sieh dir den Hund an!
Nochmals ein Hund. 200?
Das ist ja ... Puma.
- Ja.
Und dann dieser, Mann!
Auch dieses Rote - megaschön!
Ah, nice! Freddy Krueger.
Die kosten auch irgendwie 10'000 Fr.
Ist das der "Fuck Bush"?
# Das ist so sweet!
* Sanfte Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
nie nie nie nie nöd am Bügle.
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
schaffe alles, Motherfucker!
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
nie nie nie nie nöd am Bügle.
Da muss ich raten,
welcher der Fake ist, oder?
Das ist der Fake.
- Nein.
Das ist der Fake,
das ist der Original.
Crazy!
- Hast du das Video gesehen?
Ja, ich habe das Video gesehen.
Knallhart im HB zersägt.
Sie wollten damit
ein Statement setzen.
Also zerstörten sie den Schuh ganz.
Ich finde die Idee lustig.
Das sollte man
vielleicht öfters machen.
Es ist
eine ziemlich schwierige Frage
bezüglich
der Nachhaltigkeitsgeschichte usw.
Da gibt es schon Trends,
bei denen sich die Leute fragen:
"Ist das wirklich nötig?
Ich habe eigentlich genug."
Als Individuum ist es schwierig,
grosse Veränderungen zu machen.
Klar, können wir anfangen,
aber von der Politik
und den grossen Brands
sollten stärkere Zeichen kommen.
Es ist zwar gut für mich, dass die
Leute für Schuhe viel Geld ausgeben.
Ich selber
würde sie für mich nicht kaufen.
Aber ich verkaufe sie.
Was ich hier noch habe,
ist ein Jordan von Travis Scott.
Travis Scott
ist ein US-amerikanischer Rapper.
Der Schuh kam für 190 Fr. raus.
Er ist sehr limitiert.
Darum kostet er jetzt
2'000 bis 2'300 Dollar.
Neben den Schuhen habe ich
auch die Müesli von Travis Scott.
Sie kamen nur in Amerika raus
und waren entsprechend limitiert.
Und der Retailpreis
lag um die 40 Dollar,
was auch schon ziemlich viel ist.
Der Resellpreis
liegt bei 100 bis 150 Dollar.
Also etwas Gewinn
liegt da immer noch drin.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Murda on the beat
so it's not nice.
# For this life, I cannot change.
# Hidden Hills,
deep off in the main.
# M&M's, sweet like candy cane.
# Drop the top, pop it, let it bang,
pop it, pop it.
# For this life, I cannot change.
# Hidden Hills,
deep off in the main.
# M&M's, sweet like candy cane.
# Drop the pop, pop it, let it bang,
pop it, pop it.
# Drop the top, play hide and seek.
# Jump inside,
jump straight to the lake.
# Take a sip, feel just how I be.
Wir sind ein bisschen der Feind
der Sammler,
weil sie halt nicht
an ihre Sneaker herankommen.
Aber sie sind auch
ein bisschen selber schuld,
weil sie sich nicht genug Mühe
geben, an die Schuhe heranzukommen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Z'vil Empathie
laht e Nigga slippe.
# Worldlife muess no viel lehre.
# Nimm mini Kindness
nie für Weakness.
# Wil d'Limbs sind scharf
wie ir inch Era.
# Sie säged ich heg mich veränderet
# aber ich bi immer
no dr gliich Nigga.
# En z'grosse Hunger
isch mis Handicap.
# Sobald's lauft
wend sie dich kenne.
Ich nutze sozusagen
einfach den Moment aus.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Der Konsum in unserer Gesellschaft
ist ... ähm ...
... abnormal hoch.
Wir geben viel zu viel Geld aus
für Sachen,
die man nicht wirklich braucht.
All dieses Zeug
müssen wir hinterfragen.
Wo kommen meine Kleider her?
Wo kommen meine Unterhosen her?
Ja, alles.
Es muss alles hinterfragt werden
und nicht nur das,
was ich mache.
Ich will mich einfach
in der Gesellschaft eingliedern
und meinen Beitrag dazu leisten,
dass sich unsere Welt verbessert.
Aber ich habe keine Idee,
wie man das ändern könnte.
Darüber habe ich mir noch nicht
wirklich Gedanken gemacht.
# These bitches want Nikes.
# They looking for a check.
# Tell em it ain't likely.
# Said she need a ring like Carmelo.
Ich habe mir vor zwei Jahren
ein Limit gesetzt,
bei dem ich mir gesagt habe:
"Ich kaufe mir keinen Schuh mehr,
der mehr als 500 Fr. kostet."
Dieses Limit habe ich einmal
bei einem Dior-Sneaker gebrochen,
aber sonst ...
Seit zwei Jahren
bin ich sozusagen clean.
# Kuckuck.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Ich habe genug von Lügen
und Ausbeutungen.
Ich bin gegen
das kapitalistische System,
weil es ungerecht ist.
Ich bin Jani Leinonen,
Künstler aus Finnland.
* Er sagt etwas auf Finnisch. *
Spiritualität,
Solidarität und Freundschaft
werden meiner Meinung nach
vom Kapitalismus
mit der Gier nach Geld ersetzt.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
# Kuckuck.
Es ist ein bisschen wie ein Rausch.
Es ist eine grosse Euphorie.
Du freust dich einfach darüber,
dass du ein so tolles Schnäppchen
gemacht hast.
Manchmal
fühle ich mich auch schuldig,
dass ich zu dieser Konsum-
gesellschaft auch etwas beitrage.
Aber grösstenteils
sind es positive Gefühle.
Ich bin Rafi, 23-jährig und
leidenschaftlicher Schnäppchenjäger.
Mit den Schnäppchen ...
Das ist das Lustige:
Ich bin per Zufall
auf preispirat.ch darauf gestossen.
Das war vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Ich sah:
Es gab eine Rabattaktion bei Hiltl -
von 99 %.
Ich reservierte gleich im Hiltl.
Dann ging ich dort
mit fünf Kollegen essen.
Und es war wirklich so:
Es gab wirklich 99 % Rabatt.
Ich war nicht von Anfang an
Feuer und Flamme dafür,
überhaupt nicht,
aber mit der Zeit merkte ich schon,
dass es gar nicht so falsch ist,
dass man das Maximum
herausholen will.
Denn eben: Sonst ist es ja
wie verschenktes Geld.
Da kam ich immer mehr hinein.
Ich suche Schnäppchen
v.a. auf toppreise.ch,
dann natürlich die Tagesangebote
von Digitec usw.
Dann gibt es noch Gutscheine,
z.B. in den Zeitungen.
Ich bekomme noch Broschüren
nach Hause geliefert.
Da sehe ich auch nach,
ob es ein gutes Angebot gibt.
Pro Tag verbringe ich
etwa zwei Stunden damit,
nach Deals zu suchen.
Und ich würde sagen,
ich gucke jede Stunde auf Preispirat
oder auf Toppreise nach,
ob es dort schon etwas Neues gibt.
Dort gibt es auch so eine Übersicht,
bei der man
die stärksten Preissenkungen sieht.
Ich schaue jeweils nach, ob sich in
der letzten Stunde was geändert hat.
Mein Interesse,
dass ich solche Deals einschicke
und auf Preispirat aktiv bin,
rührt daher, dass ich sparen möchte,
denn ich bin Student.
Ich brauche das Geld.
Ein weiterer Grund ist,
dass ich mir Sachen leisten kann,
die ich mir nie
hätte leisten können -
oder zumindest nicht
in einem solchen Ausmass.
Andererseits aber auch, dass man
den Leuten verklickern will,
dass wir z.T.
ziemlich verarscht werden
und dass man das nicht einfach
so hinnehmen und akzeptieren sollte.
Bei sehr guten Schnäppchen
schlage ich manchmal
wirklich sehr impulsiv zu.
Das ist mit einer bestimmten Freude
verbunden.
Dann, im Nachhinein,
kommt ein Schuldgefühl,
wenn ich merke, dass ich es
eigentlich gar nicht brauche.
Wirklich sehr gute Angebote
sind natürlich zeitlich befristet
oder in der Stückzahl limitiert.
Deswegen
muss man ziemlich schnell zuschlagen
und nicht lange überlegen, ob man
das wirklich braucht oder nicht.
Denn wenn man es braucht
und es nicht gekauft hat,
fühlt man sich noch blöder, als wenn
man es kauft und nicht braucht.
Man kann es immer zu
einem guten Preis weiterverkaufen.
Beim E-Bike, das ich gekauft habe,
konnte ich durch die Kumulation
von mehreren Gutscheincodes
den Preis drücken.
Ich habe im Onlineshop
etwa 23 Gutscheine
miteinander kombiniert.
Ziemlich oft sind die Gutscheine
auch numerisch ...
... nacheinander aufgeteilt.
Beim E-Bike z.B. war es so,
dass die letzten fünf Ziffern
eigentlich den Gutschein ausmachten.
Wenn man diese abändert ...
... kommt man vielleicht
auf einen Gutscheincode.
Dann kam ich am Schluss
auf etwa 10 % ...
... Einkauf.
Und ... ähm ...
Was bei solchen Preis- oder
Gutscheinfeldern auch wichtig ist,
ist, dass man
eine Filialabholung auswählt,
alles aber schon im Onlineshop
bezahlt.
Meinen Fernseher
habe ich bei melectronics gekauft.
Ich erkannte gleich, dass es ein
sehr gutes Angebot werden könnte,
wenn man die richtigen Gutscheine
miteinander kombiniert.
Da bekam man
schon 20-fache Cumulus-Punkte.
Ich konnte noch
einen zehnfachen generieren,
weil ich Famigros-Mitglied bin.
Ich musste einfach
ein Kind hinzufügen,
bei dem ich den Geburtstag
richtig geplant habe.
Nach etwa fünf Tagen
kam der Gutscheincode dann.
Das waren dann schon mal 30 %.
Dann hatte ich noch
einen elffachen Gutscheincode
von der Genossenschaft Zürich.
Und dann nochmals 5 %,
weil ich in der Migros
einen Grosseinkauf machte,
und nochmals zweifach.
So kam ich auf insgesamt 48 %.
Dann bekam ich den Fernseher
statt für 1'800 Fr.
irgendwie für 980 Fr.
Und Katzenfutter
habe ich auch im Wert von ...
... 360 Fr. gekauft.
Effektiv
habe ich 180 Fr. ausgegeben.
Wenn sich die Händler
nichts dabei überlegen
und einfach so eine einfache
Gutscheingenerierung machen,
sind sie eigentlich selber schuld,
wenn die Leute dahinterkommen
und wissen:
"Aha, es sind nur die letzten
fünf Zahlen, die man ändern muss."
Dann sollen sie
personalisierte Gutscheine einführen
oder mit Buchstaben und Zahlen,
die viel schwieriger
herauszufinden sind.
In meinen Augen
ist das kein Beschiss.
Das ist einfach die Ignoranz
dieser Händler,
die man ausnutzen darf.
Unser Verlangen nach Konsum
ist sicher
von den Möglichkeiten beeinflusst,
die wir haben.
In erster Linie ist es das Geld.
Und wir werden überall
mit Werbung konfrontiert.
Das stachelt uns dazu an,
Sachen einzukaufen.
Und dann natürlich
auch gewissermassen,
dass man sich sozusagen profiliert,
dass man sich zeigt,
dass man mit bestimmten Produkten
angibt.
Es ist ein bisschen wie
ein Teufelskreis, würde ich sagen,
denn wenn der eine etwas hat,
sieht es der andere und sagt:
"Cool, das will ich auch haben!"
Ich stehe der Konsumgesellschaft
eher kritisch gegenüber,
wobei ich mich auch als Opfer
dieser Konsumgesellschaft sehe.
Ich versuche, meinen Konsum
auf einem möglichst tiefen Minimum
zu halten.
Natürlich
schaffe ich das nicht immer.
Ich kann auch nicht behaupten,
dass ich ein mega Ökofreak wäre,
denn ich habe einen Fernseher,
ein Smartphone - alles Mögliche.
Das ist halt der Luxus,
den wir haben und haben dürfen.
Aber es ist gleichermassen
auch unser Fluch,
dass wir uns nie mit dem
zufriedengeben, was wir haben,
und immer das Neuere und Beste
wollen.
Ich persönlich
bin kein Fan von Black Friday,
wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Da heisst es wieder:
"Kauft dies! Kauft jenes!"
"Kauft es, weil es günstig ist,
und nicht, weil ihr es braucht!"
Das finde ich natürlich
nicht so gut.
Andererseits finde ich es gut,
dass dadurch ein Wettkampf
zwischen den Händlern entsteht
und dass Preise unterboten werden,
die man nicht
für möglich gehalten hätte,
Preise, die schon fast gestört sind.
Von daher
hat es sicher seinen Nutzen,
aber es hat auch seine Nachteile.
Die meisten Kritikpunkte,
die ich in den Zeitungen lese,
sind Unglaube.
Sie sagen:
"Das ist doch gar nicht so!"
Und: "Ihr kauft Sachen,
die ihr gar nicht braucht."
Und ein weiterer Kritikpunkt
ist derjenige
mit der Konsumwegwerfgesellschaft.
Dem stimme ich auch zu.
Aber ich würde fast behaupten,
dass Leute wie ich,
die so viele Schnäppchen machen,
diese Sachen viel mehr wertschätzen
als Leute,
die sich das einfach spontan kaufen
und sich dabei nicht viel überlegen.
Wir planen das auch immer schön
und überlegen uns:
"Wann könnte ich das gebrauchen?"
"In welchem Zeitraum
sollte ich das gekauft haben?"
Es ist mir sicher wichtig,
wie mich andere Personen auffassen.
Es ist mir aber v.a. auch wichtig,
dass sie mich nicht
als Geizkragen betrachten,
weil ich einfach sparen will,
das auf jeden Fall,
sondern dass sie mich
einfach eher als ...
... geldbewussten,
finanzbewussten Menschen sehen.
Hey!
- Ciao!
Alles klar?
- Geht's dir gut?
Und euch?
- Auch.
Meine Kollegen
haben ziemlich überrascht reagiert -
oder reagieren ziemlich überrascht -
auf meine Schnäppchenleidenschaft.
Sie finden sie
auch ein bisschen freaky, aber ...
Sie schreiben mich nicht ab.
Sie ziehen ja auch
einen Vorteil daraus,
wenn sie mal etwas brauchen.
Aber es ist sicher
nicht etwas Normales.
Ja, genau!
Ich wünschte mir, dass die Händler
gar keine Gutscheincodes einführen
und die Sachen von Anfang an
reduziert anbieten würden.
Dann müsste ich die Codes nicht
jedes Mal scannen und mir überlegen:
"Habe ich den und den gescannt?"
Das ist viel zu aufwendig
und zu undurchsichtig für die User.
Es sind ein paar Auserwählte,
die wissen,
dass es den Gutscheincode gibt.
Ich finde das schlecht.
Das sollte für jedermann
zugänglich sein.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen,
dass ich von dieser Schnäppchenjagd
auf jeden Fall profitiert habe.
Ich habe schon viele gute Deals
gemacht.
Es gab sicher auch schon Tage, an
denen ich eher weniger profitierte,
aber wenn man
alles zusammen ansieht,
habe ich sicher einen
sehr grossen Mehrwert bekommen.
Sonst würde ich es
auch nicht weitermachen,
wenn es anders gewesen wäre.
# Kuckuck.
* Sanfte Musik *
Warum fällt es uns allen so leicht,
uns einen Asteroiden vorzustellen,
der alles Leben auf der Erde
zerstört?
Aber wir können uns das Ende
des Kapitalismus nicht vorstellen.
# Kuckuck.
Ich machte ursprünglich mal eine
Lehre als Detailhandelsangestellter.
Leider Gottes
arbeitete ich ein halbes Jahr lang
bei einem der grössten
Elektrofachmärkte in der Schweiz.
Ich empfand das als
die schlimmste Zeit meines Lebens.
Es waren sechs Monate,
in denen ich ...
... wirklich auch merkte ...
... wie vergiftet die Leute
konsumieren wollen,
was für einen krassen Stellenwert
das einnimmt
und wie die Leute sich vergessen,
wenn es darum geht:
"Kriege ich das?"
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, ich würde mich
als Antikapitalisten bezeichnen.
Ich bin fest davon überzeugt,
dass das System,
so, wie wir es jetzt leben,
sich selber an die Wand fahren wird.
Ich bin Philippe und bin 33.
Ich wohne in Bern
in einer grossen WG
in einer gemeinsamen Ökonomie.
Ich gründete vor zwei Jahren
ein Start-up und bin Unternehmer.
Wir sind acht Erwachsene
und drei Kinder.
Es gibt Sozialarbeiterinnen
und einen Sexualpädagogen,
eine Gesangspädagogin,
eine Theologiestudentin,
einen Medienschaffenden,
einen Musikschaffenden -
also eine sehr bunte Truppe.
Grundsätzlich sind wir eine
Wohngemeinschaft und keine Kommune.
"Kommune" ist ein Wort,
das die Medien gerne benutzen.
Es wird mit viel assoziiert,
was hier nicht passiert.
Wir haben keine Orgien
und keine Gelage in diesem Sinne.
Wir wohnen aber gemeinschaftlich
und sehr nahe beieinander.
Wir teilen uns nicht nur das Haus
und die Haushaltsbeschaffungen,
sondern auch unser Geld.
Die gemeinsame Ökonomie bedeutet,
dass wir unsere Einkommen
zusammen auf einem Konto verwalten.
Von diesem Konto
bezahlen wir all unsere Ausgaben.
Wir bestreiten unser Leben
mit dem Geld,
das uns zur Verfügung steht.
Wir haben eine Karte.
Diese benutzen wir ganz normal -
wie unsere Bank-
oder Postkontokarte.
Es gibt überhaupt keine Regelungen
oder Bestimmungen.
Jeder kann walten und schalten,
wie er möchte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Als ich das zum ersten Mal hörte,
dachte ich: "Seid ihr wahnsinnig?"
Also ich glaube,
meine erste Reaktion auf ...
... die gemeinsame Ökonomie
war gleich wie diejenige
meiner Freunde und Familie.
Ich war sehr erstaunt,
dass es - erstens -
überhaupt ein solches Konzept gibt.
Und zweitens:
viel Unverständnis
für die Idee an sich.
Es ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes
als eine grosse Familie.
Ich glaube, es sind Strukturen, die
früher viel mehr so gelebt wurden
und sich erst
in den letzten 40, 50 Jahren
so etabliert haben.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, vielleicht ist unser Garten
wie ein Spiegel von dem,
wie wir gerne leben.
Wir lassen es gerne leben -
wie man sieht.
Das ist während der Sommermonate
ein guter Zustupf
für unsere Haushaltskasse.
Wir haben eben
einen ziemlich grossen Garten,
aber nicht so, dass man
längerfristig davon leben könnte.
Mmh!
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir leben in einer Gesellschaft,
in welcher der Mensch dazu tendiert,
sein Glück
über den Konsum zu befriedigen.
Das ist eine Vorstellung, die ich
sehr gut nachvollziehen kann.
Ich funktionierte selber auch so
und tue es immer noch:
"Konsumieren macht glücklich."
Aber es ist einfach sehr kurzlebig.
Es ist so ...
... ein Glück,
das einem für den Moment etwas gibt.
Schlussendlich
ist es aber nicht das Glück,
das du im Leben suchst.
Das ist nicht das, was du bekommst,
wenn du dich geborgen
und als Teil von etwas fühlst.
So!
Wie spät ist es?
Die Zeit vergeht nämlich schnell.
* Sanfte Musik *
Also, gehen wir ... ähm ...
Rafi hat ja das Finanzamt.
Ähm ...
Ich habe heute kurz nachgesehen,
wie es mit dem Kontostand aussieht.
Nicht so schlecht.
Es ist ... äh ...
Also es sind 6'500 Fr. oder so
auf dem Konto.
Dein Lohn
ist noch nicht auf dem Konto.
Ja,
wir haben gerade unsere Haussitzung,
unser Plenum, das wir
alle zwei bis drei Wochen abhalten -
je nachdem,
wie die Leute da sind oder nicht.
Da geht es eben auch darum,
dass wir abschätzen können:
Reicht es? Oder müssen wir
noch Geld vom Ersparten nehmen?
"Bei mir steht das an.
Ich würde gerne das kaufen."
Oder: "Das wird kommen."
Wir haben eine Zahl gesucht, die
irgendwie in einem Mittelmass ist,
so, dass man ...
... unabhängig und individuell
trotzdem Sachen kaufen kann,
auf die man Lust hat,
ohne dass man es anmelden muss.
Wir haben uns auf 400 Fr. geeinigt.
400 Fr. ist der Betrag,
bei dem man sein Bedürfnis
anmelden kann oder sollte.
Ich glaube,
wichtig ist noch zu erwähnen,
dass wir Bedürfnisse
nicht verhandeln,
sondern man überlegt, wie man
das Bedürfnis befriedigen kann.
Noch eine Frage zu den GAs:
Wann kommt das genau?
Meines ist bis Ende Oktober gültig.
Meines ist erst im November
oder Dezember fällig.
Ich würde sagen,
wir lassen es einfach mal laufen.
Ja.
Und wir reagieren, wenn wir sehen,
dass wir wirklich eine Lücke haben.
Wir wenden ... äh ...
... alle zwei oder drei Wochen
15 oder 30 Minuten auf,
um die gemeinsame Ökonomie ...
... ähm ... zu verwalten.
Gleichzeitig haben wir aber eine
enorme Unabhängigkeit und Freiheit.
Wir haben z.B. ein Rechnungsamt.
Ich lege meine Rechnungen in ein
Fach und dann werden diese bezahlt.
Dann kann man das sparen.
Also ich bin überzeugt:
Ich gewinne mehr,
als dass ich investiere.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich brauche zwischen
2'000 und 3'000 Fr. im Monat.
Mit 2'000, 3'000 Fr. im Monat ...
... gehe ich eigentlich
ziemlich angenehm und ...
... ohne Verzicht durchs Leben.
Jetzt bin ich auf dem Weg ...
... nach Urtenen-Schönbühl,
zu unserem
neuen Genossenschaftsprojekt,
an dem wir
seit fast eineinhalb Jahren sind.
Ich unterstütze
den Baustellensupport
und helfe beim Kochen.
* Popmusik *
Ja, es ist eine wahre Freude,
hier reinzukommen.
So cool!
Es ist mir sehr wichtig -
im Sinne von:
Wir gehen einen Schritt weiter.
Wir vergrössern uns.
Wir wachsen.
Wir können neue Leute
für unsere Idee gewinnen.
Für mich persönlich
ist es auch ein Traum,
ein eigenes Haus zu bauen.
Zusammen hat man halt einfach
einen grösseren, finanziellen Hebel
und mehr Möglichkeiten,
ein solches Projekt zu realisieren,
als wenn man z.B.
in einer Kernfamilie
ein solches Projekt angehen würde.
Dort unten sind Kekse.
Muss man noch
den Käse bereit machen?
Soll ich ein Pack rausstellen?
- Ja!
Das Essen ist das Wichtigste,
damit der Bau gut läuft.
Darum geben wir uns immer Mühe,
dass es etwas Köstliches
zu essen gibt.
Von der Organisation her ist es so,
dass wir uns gegen eine
grosse Baufirma entschieden haben,
gegen eine Generalunternehmung,
und lieber in kleineren Unternehmen,
die auch genossenschaftlich
organisiert sind, arbeiten.
Hey, wer hat gekocht? Chrigel?
Geile Suppe!
Mmh!
Wir finanzieren dieses Projekt
einerseits aus Eigenmitteln
und andererseits aus Darlehen
und Genossenschaftsanteilen,
die wir von ganz vielen,
grosszügigen Menschen
bekommen haben.
Ich persönlich hätte nie gedacht,
dass wir das ...
... finanziell stemmen können -
alleine schon nur,
wenn du diese Zahlen hörst.
Es sind riesige Zahlen!
Aber das Schöne ist, dass man sich
dann auch gegenseitig in der Gruppe
abholen und einander beruhigen kann.
Ja, das ist eine weitere Stärke
der Gemeinschaft.
Also Frühstück eine Stunde
und am Mittag zwei Stunden gekocht.
Nachher habe ich oben ...
- Hast du geputzt, oder was?
Genau, ich habe oben geputzt.
- Okay.
Das war am 22.
- Einfach gekocht?
Ja.
- Wie lange?
Drei Stunden.
- Mit Mittag?
Ja.
Ich habe mit ihm noch kurz
meine Einsätze besprochen
von den Baustellenrapporten,
die wir ausfüllen.
Wir füllen sie aus dem Grund aus,
weil unsere Bank ...
... Arbeitszeit
als Eigenkapital anrechnet
und wir das denen belegen
und dokumentieren müssen.
Ohne unsere Eigenleistung,
ohne diese Möglichkeit,
wäre dieses Projekt
nicht finanzierbar gewesen.
Ich denke, jeder in der Gemeinschaft
versucht auch,
nach seinem Einkommen
sein Leben zu bestreiten.
Natürlich haben wir sehr stark
die solidarische Komponente,
was ich mega wichtig finde.
Im Sinne von:
Man kann auch mal einen Monat lang
keinen Lohn bringen.
Man kann sich eine Auszeit nehmen
oder in meinem Fall
ein Unternehmen gründen.
Man kann sich halt nicht jeden Monat
einen Lohn auszahlen.
Das ist nur möglich,
weil ich in dieser Gemeinschaft
auch so aufgefangen werde.
* Popmusik *
Und jetzt
sind wir in der Herba di Berna.
Das ist unser Start-up, das wir
vor zwei Jahren gegründet haben.
Hier kultivieren wir CBD-Hanf.
Es ist nicht  m e i n  Geschäft.
Die Herba di Berna
ist eine Aktiengesellschaft
und die Hauptaktionärin der Herba
ist unsere gemeinsame Ökonomie.
Dementsprechend kommt auch das,
was ich hier erwirtschafte,
also das,
was ich als Lohn bekomme ...
... wieder zurück
in die gemeinsame Ökonomie.
Geld ist ein nötiges Übel.
Ich glaube,
das ist meine Beziehung zum Geld.
Geld ermöglicht einem vieles.
Darum brauchen wir auch Geld.
Darum müssen wir dieses Unternehmen
auch so führen,
dass es auf irgendeine Art und Weise
der Wirtschaftlichkeitsprämisse
untersteht.
Wir können das nicht
wegphilosophieren,
das bringt nichts.
Wir unterliegen dem Markt genauso
wie unsere Konkurrenz
und unsere Marktteilnehmer.
Ich versuche einfach,
mein Leben so zu leben,
dass ich mir
die Herzenswünsche erfüllen kann,
die für mich wirklich wichtig sind.
Dafür setze ich meine Energie ein.
Ich wende in dem Sinn
weniger Energie
für irgendwelche Konsumartikel
und Güter auf,
die man sich ja auch verdienen muss
und für die man auch arbeiten muss.
Es ist eine anstrengende Zeit.
Wenn man ein Unternehmen führt,
ein Haus baut,
sich politisch engagiert
und die Welt verändern will,
hat man einfach keine Zeit,
um nichts zu tun.
Das ist doch mal ein Schlusswort,
was?
Ist es gerade?
Nein, es ist nicht gerade, oder?
So gut!
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich glaube,
ich sehe dieser ganzen Sache
mit dem Alter ...
Ja, ich habe
eine andere Perspektive dazu.
Was wir jetzt hier gerade aufbauen,
soll weitergedacht
auch ein Stück weit
eine Altersvorsorge sein.
Diese Vorstellung
finde ich total schön:
einen Ort zu haben,
wo man hinkommen kann,
mehrere Generationen zusammenleben
und dieses solidarische
Zusammenwohnen auch gelebt wird.
# Kuckuck.
Warum sagen sie uns allen,
dass es möglich ist,
ein Raumschiff zu mieten,
um zum Mond zu fliegen,
aber unmöglich, den Menschen
ihre Grundrechte zu geben?
# Kuckuck.
Gleich nach der Werbung:
Xenia verführt im Auftrag der Kunden
Follower und Fans.
Marketingexperte Aldo Gnocchi zeigt,
wie Onlinehändler Konsumenten
zu ihren Produkten lotsen.
Die Post am Limit:
350'000 Pakete pro Tag
werden in Härkingen verarbeitet.
Am Black Friday sind es über 500'000.
Auf einer Schrotthalde
können zwar Tausende Menschen
ein paar Cents mit
recyclebaren Rohstoffen verdienen,
die Folgen sind aber verheerend.
Als der Mensch in der Höhle lebte,
war die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Er war Jäger und Sammler.
Er brauchte nicht viele Dinge:
etwas zum Anziehen
und einen Speer zum Jagen.
Heute besitzt ein Europäer
10'000 Dinge.
Wie konnte das passieren?
Der Mensch ist immer noch Jäger
und immer noch Sammler,
aber es gibt viel mehr zu jagen
und zu sammeln.
Der Mensch jagt Schnäppchen,
Aktionen, Rabatte, Gelegenheiten -
und dabei sammelt er Zeug.
Zum Kochen
gab es früher einfach Feuer.
Heute gibt es dafür einen Herd,
den Backofen, die Mikrowelle,
die Kaffeemaschine, den Steamer,
den Toaster und den Grill.
Und den Brotbackautomaten,
den Thermomix und die Fritteuse.
Welche Vorteile hat eine elektrische
Fritteuse gegenüber einer Pfanne?
Sie hat einen Thermostat,
der dafür sorgt,
dass das Öl
die richtige Temperatur hat.
Wenn das erreicht ist,
geht die Lampe aus.
Dann kann man den Korb ins Öl legen.
Aber man kann noch andere
tolle Sachen für die Küche kaufen:
den Knoblauchschneider,
den Bananenschneider,
den Wassermelonenschneider,
die Apfelschälmaschine,
die Zwiebelbrille,
die Burgerpresse,
das Spaghettimass
und den Kirschkernentferner.
Mit diesen Dingen
geht Kochen ganz leicht.
* Schrei *
Wo viel gekocht wird,
wird viel gegessen.
Wenn man zu viel isst, wird man dick.
Wenn man zu dick ist,
macht man eine Diät.
Und auch da gibt es viele:
z.B. FDH: "Friss die Hälfte".
Oder Intervallfasten:
zwei Tage in der Woche nichts essen.
Oder die Paleo-Diät: nur noch essen,
was es in der Steinzeit gab.
Vielleicht funktionieren diese Diäten
auch beim Konsum.
KDH: "Kauf die Hälfte".
Intervallfasten:
zwei Tage in der Woche nichts kaufen.
Oder die Paleo-Diät: nur noch kaufen,
was es in der Steinzeit gab.
Dann fängt alles wieder von vorne an.
# Kuckuck.
Sie versuchen, uns alles
als Diätprodukte zu verkaufen:
Bier ohne Alkohol,
Kaffee ohne Koffein,
Eiscreme ohne Fett.
Es ist an der Zeit,
Diät-Revolutionen zu stoppen
und eine richtige durchzuführen.
# Kuckuck.
C'est un petit peu trop sombre ici.
Tu vois? Non?
Ce cote la, c'est tres sombre.
Ich bin ein wenig ein Kontrollfreak.
Für mich ist das wichtig.
Deswegen liebe ich das Internet,
denn ich kann für mich selber
entscheiden.
Yeah, better.
Oh yeah, much better!
Yes. Now you can see me.
Like me. Click me. Buy me.
Die digitale Verführung.
Man muss einen
gesunden Menschenverstand haben,
wenn man herumsurft
und dort unterwegs ist.
Man muss wissen, dass Unternehmen
sehr interessiert sind
an allen Datenspuren,
die wir hinterlegen.
Diese können sie gezielt einsetzen,
um mich wieder mit personalisierter
Werbung anzusprechen.
* Popmusik *
# Who you are?
Ich bin Aldo Gnocchi. Ich bin 37.
Ich bin Unternehmer
im Bereich Digitales Marketing.
Ich doziere an Hochschulen wie
der Fachhochschule Nordwestschweiz.
* Popmusik *
Ich begebe mich heute
auf eine Customer Journey
und will mir einen Active-
Noise-Cancelling-Kopfhörer kaufen.
Aldos Kundenreise beginnt.
Phase 1: bewusst sein.
Da ich bald in die Ferien verreise
und im Flugzeug entspannen will.
* Popmusik *
Hallo, ich bin Xenia Tchoumi.
Ich arbeite als Instagram-,
Facebook-
und Soziale-Netzwerke-Expertin -
und als Influencerin.
Ich habe mehr als 1,5 Mio. Follower
auf Instagram.
Und ich habe - puh! - fast 6 Mio.
auf Facebook.
* Popmusik *
Ich habe Content kreiert
und mehr Content kreiert.
Und nie gestoppt. Mit viel Konstanz.
Ich hatte Glück, dass einige
grosse Pages auf Facebook
meinen Content verteilt haben.
Alles organisch?
- Ja, ja, 100 %.
Wenn ich eine Google-Suche starte,
passiert auf diesen Plattformen
relativ viel.
Ich gebe Keywords ein und diese
sind ein Trigger für Werbeanzeigen.
Das kann der Shopping-Feed sein,
der mir zum Keyword
passende Produkte anzeigt.
Wenn ich eine solche Plattform
besuche, wird getrackt,
dass mein Interesse da ist.
Wenn eine Kampagne läuft,
eine automatisierte,
kann man den ganzen Produktkatalog
dieser Onlineshops verknüpfen.
Mit den Plattformen Google,
Facebook usw.
kann man dann
gleich ein Remarketing machen.
Das ist dann, wenn ich im Internet
von diesen Produkten verfolgt werde.
Remarketing erinnert den Kunden,
dass er sich für ein Produkt
interessiert hat.
Besucht er eine Website,
erhält er ein Cookie.
Dieses wird
auf seinem Gerät gespeichert.
Surft er weiter, sieht er womöglich
Werbung von z.B. Kopfhörern.
So wird das Verhalten des Konsumenten
online verfolgt.
* Popmusik *
Von unseren Kunden kennen wir
grundsätzlich die Informationen,
die sie uns geben:
Postleitzahl und die Adresse.
Wir machen damit aber normalerweise
keine Marketingmassnahmen.
Spannender sind eigentlich die Ver-
haltensdaten bei uns im Onlineshop,
welche Kategorien ein Kunde besuchte
und welche Produkte er sich ansah.
Wir schauen uns
eine Gruppe von Kunden an,
die sich ähnlich verhält.
Wir versuchen, aus diesen Infor-
mationen gezielt das herauszufinden,
was in der nächsten Werbung
vorkommen sollte.
* Popmusik *
Influencer sind insofern
ein Teil der Customer Journey,
als dass sie
ein Bedürfnis wecken können.
Sie können inspirieren.
Sie können auf neue Produkte
aufmerksam machen.
Und da fängt die Customer Journey
eigentlich an.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin heute hier in Genf -
v.a. bei Moet & Chandon.
Diese Marken finden mich immer!
* Popmusik *
# All night long.
Wir sind hier,
um es zu geniessen, aber auch,
um Kontakte zu knüpfen -
als Influencer.
Hallo, meine Leute!
Ich spreche selten Deutsch.
Aber wir sind hier
mit dem Schweizer Fernsehen.
Oh, die Blumen stehen dir so gut!
- Ja, finde ich auch.
Ja.
Wir filmen an der Moet-Party.
Ca va?
Yeah.
- He's like: "Yeah."
"Yeah!"
Share, ready, steady, go!
Shared!
Instagram?
- Ja.
Jetzt sehen uns 7 Mio. Leute?
Und ich mit den Blumen?
- Ja, schön, oder?
Sagst du mir jetzt noch,
wie viel du verdienst?
Warum bist du so neugierig?
- Das ist mein Beruf.
Sicher ist es nur wegen des Berufs.
Was lässt ihr euch
das Engagement von Xenia kosten?
Na ja, das Engagement von Xenia ...
Da möchte ich nicht
darüber sprechen.
Das muss sie vielleicht sagen.
Ich kann ...
Sie wollte nichts dazu sagen.
- Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Aber ich kann vielleicht etwas
dazu sagen,
wie wir bei Moet Hennessy normaler-
weise mit Influencern umgehen:
Sie werden bei uns nicht bezahlt.
Wir bieten ihnen an,
zu Events zu kommen,
zu denen nicht jeder Zugang hat
und geben ihnen Goodies,
was in Richtung Exklusivität geht.
Ich glaube,
viele Leute verstehen nicht,
dass es bei einem Influencer
nicht nur darum geht,
Produkte zu bewerben. Ich würde
sagen, das sind vielleicht 30 %.
Der Rest ist die Beziehung,
die du mit deinen Followern hast,
was deine Message ist.
Das hat nichts
nur mit Verkaufen zu tun,
sonst wäre es zu dry
und du hättest nie Follower -
oder zu wenige.
Wie viele Posts
musst du für Moet machen?
Im Vertrag haben wir zwei.
Zwei für eine Zusammenarbeit,
für eine Periode.
Auf welchen Post oder welche Story
bist du besonders stolz?
Die von gestern
hat mir gut gefallen.
Aber alles, auf das die Leute
eine positive Reaktion zeigen,
macht mich immer stolz.
Hi, guys!
I've been thinking
of using Instagram
to just speak to you
in a spontaneous way.
Try to focus on that one thing
that makes you happy
instead of the ten, twenty things
that make you feel sad!
And try to think about it
and make it bigger in your head!
It's kind of a trick
I start to learn
and it's working magic on my life.
So I wanted to share it with you -
like this, spontaneously.
Have a good day!
Ich glaube,
soziale Netzwerke sind ...
Auch wenn du 100 Follower hast:
Sie geben dir diesen immediate ...
... Dopamin-Hit.
Du hast ein schönes Foto
und postest es.
Es gibt sofort eine Reaktion.
Es ist wie, ja, ein bisschen
eine Droge, würde ich sagen.
Für mich ist das ...
Ich habe kein Problem.
Ich kann das kontrollieren
und verstehen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Ja, wir haben
eine erste Recherche auf Google
zu diesen Kopfhörern gemacht.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
wie die Customer Journey weitergeht.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
So bei 42 °C
ist das ein Riesenspass!
Da ich weiss,
dass manche meiner Freunde
solche Kopfhörer benutzen,
habe ich mir
eine Auswahl von Menschen gemacht,
von denen ich finde, sie könnten mir
ihre Erfahrung teilen.
Es werden aber ziemlich sicher
noch weitere darauf einsteigen.
Wie und wo überall versuchen Sie,
Ihre Kunden online zu erreichen?
Wir versuchen,
unsere Kunden auf allen Plattformen
und Platzierungen zu erreichen,
die irgendwie möglich sind.
Letztlich
muss unsere Werbung dort laufen,
wo sich der Kunde aufhält.
Das mag im einen Fall
ein Mobile Device sein -
vielleicht ein Feed auf Instagram
oder Facebook,
vielleicht ein Display-Ad
auf einer Newsplattform.
Unsere Werbemassnahmen
haben immer zum Ziel,
dass wir dem Kunden
nichts verkaufen, was er nicht will.
Den Entscheid, etwas zu kaufen,
fällt der Kunde ja immer am Schluss.
Und es gehört
ein Check-out-Prozess dazu.
Also sogar ich, der sagt,
er sei resistent,
weil er die Mechanismen versteht,
auch ich merke nachher:
"Okay, jetzt hat es wirklich
einen Einfluss."
"Jetzt ist es in meinem Kopf drin.
Jetzt rattert es."
Jedes Mal, wenn ich wieder
einen solchen Trigger sehe,
ein schönes Bild auf Instagram
oder auf Facebook oder wo ich bin,
befasse ich mich mit diesem Produkt.
Obwohl ich es nicht brauche,
kaufe ich es vielleicht.
* Popmusik *
Das waren die Onlineshops mit dem
grössten Umsatz in der Schweiz 2018:
amazon.de mit 660 Mio. Fr.
zalando.ch mit 785 Mio. Fr.
Digitec Galaxus mit 950 Mio. Fr.
Wie viel Prozent mehr Umsatz
machen Sie an einem Black Friday?
Genaue Zahlen
geben wir nicht heraus.
Was wir grundsätzlich
zum Black Friday sagen können,
ist,
dass es uns jedes Jahr überrascht,
wie viele Konsumenten
auf diesen Tag anspringen.
Aber ist es doppelt so viel?
Oder 30 % mehr?
Verglichen mit einem normalen Tag
ist es deutlich mehr
als doppelt so viel.
Jedes Unternehmen mit
kommerziellem Interesse versucht,
den Kunden zu erreichen.
In diesem Markt
werden Milliarden umgesetzt.
Auch wir versuchen,
mit digitalen Lösungen
auf eine personalisierte Art
den Kunden zu erreichen.
Retargeting ist
ein sinnvolles Mittel, glaube ich.
Wenn sich der Kunde etwas angeschaut
und noch keinen Kaufabschluss
gemacht hat,
ist es gut, ihn auf anderen Wegen
nochmals aufs Angebot zu bringen.
Aber wenn Sie das machen
und den Kunden daran erinnern,
dass er dieses Produkt kaufen soll
oder ihm noch ein anderes Produkt
in einer anderen Farbe zeigen,
verführen Sie ihn ja schon.
Wenn man das
"verführen" nennen möchte,
stimme ich diesem Statement
vollständig zu.
Ich würde es positiver formulieren
und es "Marketing" nennen.
Heute bin ich bei Visilab,
meinem Sponsor.
Ich bin schon lange nicht mehr
hier gewesen.
Es ist mein erstes Mal
in dieser Boutique.
Ich werde mir Brillen
für mich selbst ansehen,
denn ich habe viele Brillen
und liebe sie.
Ich bin selfmade und ich will,
dass die Leute das auch verstehen.
Ich bin z.B. Botschafterin
für die UN,
für SDG Goal for Gender Equality.
Mein Wirtschaftsstudium hilft mir
sicher bei einem Teil von dem,
was ich mache,
denn es gibt mehrere Themen.
Es ist ein Business.
Lebst du zu 100 % von dem?
- Ja, 100 %.
Und ich bin super zufrieden.
Ich würde das nicht ändern.
Wirst du das posten?
Auf Stories sicher, ja.
Zu 100 %.
Warum ist es schön?
Es zeigt die Geschichte,
wo ich bin, was ich mache,
und die Brille.
Diese Sonnenbrille gefällt mir
sehr gut. Es ist mein Stil.
Kaufst du sie?
- Wahrscheinlich.
Ich muss überlegen,
denn sie sind ziemlich teuer,
aber ich bin schon verliebt.
Du verdienst ja gutes Geld.
Du kannst es dir leisten, oder?
Ja, aber ich habe in meinem Leben
auch Spesen.
Es ist nicht nur den ganzen Tag
Shopping.
Die Zukunft dieses Marktes
kann wirklich
unglaubliche Science-Fiction werden.
Es gibt schon Avatars von Leuten,
die digital kreiert wurden.
Wird es irgendwann
einen Avatar von Xenia geben,
dem man folgen kann?
Gute Frage. Ich weiss es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Mittlerweile sind schon ziemlich
viele Empfehlungen reingekommen.
Interessant ist, dass Bose und Sony
das Rennen machen.
Aufpassen! Da kommt Verkehr!
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Wir haben zwei Noise-Cancelling-
Kopfhörer im Angebot.
Beide kosten 329 Fr.
Gemäss diesem Review müsste man sich
eigentlich für Sony entscheiden:
USB-C-Anschluss, besserer Sound ...
Ich würde sagen,
Sony hat die Nase vorn.
Zwei Minuten und zehn Sekunden -
aber du kamst auf den Punkt.
Also gut!
- Eine Frage, Aurel.
Ja?
Ist es dein Ziel, dass die
Konsumenten möglichst beide kaufen?
Oder ist es dein Ziel,
eine klare Empfehlung abzugeben?
Wenn ich eine klare Empfehlung habe,
gebe ich eine ab,
aber ich habe keine.
Uns ist es am Ende des Tages egal,
welches Produkt die Kunden kaufen.
Beide sind gut.
Aufgrund des Brands würde ich
wahrscheinlich Bose nehmen -
auch, wenn sie technisch gesehen
schlechter wären.
Ja, jetzt schauen wir mal,
wo sie am günstigsten sind
und wo ich sie bekomme.
Ah! So interessant!
Das ist jetzt Werbung mit Kopfhörern
von Media Markt.
Anscheinend weiss Facebook jetzt,
dass sich ein User
gerade Kopfhörer ansieht.
Wir erheben relativ genau, wie viele
Kundenkontakte sinnvoll sind,
bis es zu einer Bestellung kommt,
und welche zusätzlichen Kontakte
nichts mehr bringen.
Wir versuchen,
die Kampagne dort zu stoppen,
wo es keine Bestellungen mehr gibt.
Der Kunde
hat während der Customer Journey
zwischen zehn und 20 Kontakte
mit dem Produkt - sog. Touchpoints.
Wie viele Touchpoints
hast du gebraucht?
Ich würde sagen, es waren etwa zehn.
Aber ich war in diesem Bereich
nicht ganz unerfahren.
Du versuchst immer, eine
Dissonanzverminderung hinzukriegen,
indem du dir eben einredest,
wieso es doch eine gute Idee war,
das Geld auszugeben.
Das machen Konsumenten unbewusst -
immer.
Und jetzt am Schluss
fragte ich nochmals den Verkäufer
und er fand:
"Weisst du was?
Viele Sachen sprechen für Sony."
"Es gibt
keinen grossen Unterschied."
Auch seine Arbeitskollegen
sagen genau dasselbe.
Ich wollte es nicht zulassen.
Ich war beratungsresistent,
dadurch, dass ich dogmatischer Fan
der Marke Bose bin.
# Who you are?
Schlussendlich
habe ich kein grosses Risiko.
Wenn es nichts ist, kann man innert
14 Tagen vom Kauf zurücktreten.
# When you hear what I got to say.
# Kuckuck.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich habe genug von einer Welt,
in der echte Alternativen
nicht vorstellbar sind.
Ich habe genug von einer Welt,
in der es ausreicht,
Cola-Dosen zu recyceln,
ein paar Euro für wohltätige Zwecke
an hungernde Kinder zu spenden,
nur damit wir uns wohlfühlen.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Kuckuck.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
# I can't surf.
* Unverständliche Funkdurchsage *
Guten Morgen zusammen!
- Guten Morgen, Steffi!
Guten Morgen, Steffi!
* Rasante Rockmusik *
Heutzutage ist es ...
Ja, es ist halt in der Gesellschaft
verankert, dass ...
Uns geht es halt allen sehr gut.
Und die Leute
wollen halt konsumieren -
masslos, aus meiner Sicht.
Aber das
lässt sich fast nicht ändern.
Für mich ist das ja
an und für sich etwas Gutes.
Das gibt uns immer genug Arbeit.
Das ist unser Schlepperfahrer,
der alles einlädt.
Das hier sind unsere Rollboxen.
Sie werden mit Paketen gefüllt.
Die Ortschaft
ist oben angeschrieben.
Ich habe vor 14 Jahren
hier angefangen.
Man merkt es schon:
Jedes Jahr wird es mehr.
V.a. wollen die Leute,
ich inklusive,
ihre Pakete noch schneller haben.
Deswegen haben wir es
im Tagesdienst ruhiger,
aber im Nachtdienst,
wenn es priorisiert werden muss,
nimmt es hauptsächlich
immer mehr zu.
Dann haben wir manchmal vielleicht
Schwierigkeiten, alles einzuhalten.
Die Pakete kommen in Lastwagen,
Zügen oder wie auch immer zu uns.
Die Kranführerin entlädt sie.
Sie stellt den Behälter
auf solche Abstellfüsse.
Unter diese
fährt der Platzfahrzeugfahrer,
hebt den Behälter an
und bringt ihn zu den Toren.
Hier sind die Koordinaten, damit ich
weiss, wohin ich fahren muss.
Ich bin Tanja Eggimann.
Ich bin hier seit zehn Jahren
Kranführerin.
Hier in Härkingen.
Ich bin dafür zuständig,
die Wechselbehälter
von A nach B zu stellen.
Das sind meine Sicherheitslampen.
So weiss ich,
dass hier alle vier Kontakt haben.
Mir gefällt das Kranfahren ...
... und dass ich hier oben
klare Anweisungen habe
und für mich alleine bin.
Konsum ist gut,
wenn die Leute bestellen.
D.h., dass ich Arbeit habe.
(Funk) Kannst du das bitte
noch schnell machen?
Jawohl.
Ich bin Fanta Thomas.
Ich fahre hier auf der Hoflogistik
als Platzfahrzeugfahrer.
Ich bringe eigentlich Container
von A nach B.
Z.B. diesen hier.
Ich fahre mal darunter.
Es ist mein Traumjob.
Ich bin schön für mich alleine.
Ich habe einfach meine Ruhe.
Ich kann den ganzen Tag Musik hören.
Das ist für mich sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und ich steuere selbstverständlich
sehr gerne grosse Fahrzeuge.
Platzfahrzeugfahrer bekommen
Aufträge von unserer Leitstelle.
Da heisst es: "Container Nummer 9022
muss zum Tor 220."
Der Platzfahrzeugfahrer fährt
unten rein, hebt den Container an,
bringt ihn zu Tor 220
und lädt ihn wieder ab.
Dann kommt der nächste Auftrag.
Ich bestelle sicher auch etwas.
Aber ich versuche,
es auf einem Minimum zu halten.
Zwei-, dreimal im Jahr vielleicht.
Wenn es möglich ist,
kaufe ich es auch noch selber ein,
aber das
ist halt auch nicht immer möglich.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja etwas Gutes,
wenn man die Möglichkeit hat,
fast alles zu bekommen.
An der Umsetzung, wie es ist ...
Wenn man jetzt
z.B. diverse Kleider bestellt ...
... und nachher
von den zehn Paketen mit Kleidern
neun wieder zurückschickt,
ist das alles andere als nachhaltig.
Davon bin ich kein so grosser Fan.
Die Zeit schreitet voran.
Alles wird moderner.
Geschäfte werden verschwinden.
Das lässt sich nicht vermeiden.
Das ist so wie früher, als
die Postkutschen im Wilden Westen
eigentlich vom Zug verdrängt wurden.
Das blüht halt auch den Geschäften.
Das blüht mir - als Chauffeur.
Früher oder später
werde ich wohl durch
ein autonomes Fahrzeug ersetzt.
Ja, das lässt sich nicht aufhalten.
Das ist halt die Zukunft.
Es geht immer vorwärts.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
# I can't surf.
Ich heisse Petra D'Angelo.
Ich arbeite seit 17 Jahren
als Codiererin
hier im Paketzentrum in Härkingen.
Ich erfasse Adressen, welche
die Anlage selber nicht lesen kann.
Ich denke, ich scanne
etwa 5'000 Pakete pro Tag.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin:
Manchmal bestellen wir Sachen -
ich inklusive -,
die man nicht unbedingt braucht.
Man sieht es, denkt:
"Oh, das ist noch lustig!",
und bestellt es.
Mir ergeht es nicht anders.
Ich denke,
wenn jeder darauf achten würde,
würde man vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger bestellen.
Aber das wäre ja nicht gut,
dann hätten wir weniger Arbeit.
Die grossen hier,
die zweitgrössten da
und die kleinen dort.
Dann werden sie
genau auf diese Weise sortiert.
Jemand sonst
legt sie vielleicht anders hin,
aber ich mache es so.
Es muss einfach
super anständig sein.
Die ganz schweren Pakete
haben wir unten.
Die mittleren und kleinen,
also nicht schweren, haben wir oben.
Dann müssen wir schauen:
Manchmal wird die Schachtel
schlecht zugeklebt.
Wenn das unten zusammendrückt,
fällt der ganze Stapel um.
Deswegen habe ich dieses
rübergeschoben.
Ich bin Johann Ulrich Anderegg.
Am 1. November
habe ich hier meinen letzten Tag.
Am 3. November werde ich 65.
Jetzt bin ich am Morgen meistens
hier bei Zalando eingeteilt.
Ich mache einfach
die Retoursendungen.
Das sind alles Waren,
die zurückgeschickt werden.
Sie kommen aus dem gesamten Gebiet:
aus der Innerschweiz
oder aus dem Tessin.
Bei Zalando
gibt es extrem viele Rücksendungen.
Ich selber habe keinen Computer.
Ich bestelle nicht.
Wenn ich das sagen darf:
Ich gehe lieber in die Geschäfte.
Ich mag Loeb.
Wir hatten auch noch Schild.
Heute ist das ja wieder anders.
Ich gehe lieber in die Geschäfte.
Der eine macht es so,
der andere anders.
Das ist jedem seine Sache.
* Rockmusik *
# Kuckuck.
Kunst ist eine Lüge,
welche die Wahrheit offenbart.
Und die Wahrheit ist,
dass wir über Alternativen
nachdenken müssen.
Welche soziale Organisation
kann den Kapitalismus ersetzen?
# Kuckuck.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Wir sind hier in Accra,
der Hauptstadt von Ghana.
Yo, yo, yo, what's up?
What's up? Check me! Give me hand!
Yo, what's up? What's up?
Ich bin Mathias Schluep.
Ursprünglich
bin ich Umweltingenieur.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich bin Spezialist
in Sachen Elektroschrottrecycling.
Die Schweizer Regierung
hat nicht nur mich,
sondern auch unsere Organisation
mit anderen Partnern beauftragt,
in Ghana die Regierung
und andere Partner beim Aufbau
eines nachhaltigen Recyclingsystems
für Elektroschrott zu unterstützen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Das ist jetzt der
grösste Secondhand-Markt von Accra
und in dem Sinne wahrscheinlich
auch der grösste von Ghana.
Hier bekommt man fast alles.
Hello! I'm Mathias!
In Europa, in Deutschland,
in Holland gibt es auch ...
Man nennt das
"die ghanaische Diaspora".
Also nicht,
um diese Leute schlechtzumachen.
Sie haben ihre Geschäftsbeziehungen
zu Ghana.
Sie organisieren eigentlich
den Export von gebrauchten Geräten
nach Afrika.
Okay, bye-bye!
- Bye-bye!
Dort ist Tema, der Hafen von Accra.
Es ist einer der grösseren
Handelshäfen oder -zentren
von Westafrika.
Hier werden containerweise
auch Occasionsgeräte verschifft
und gelangen hierher.
Theoretisch dürfte das, was defekt
ist und nicht mehr funktioniert,
eigentlich nicht hierhergelangen.
Gemäss der Basel-Konvention -
das ist eine UN-Konvention,
die auch die Schweiz
unterschrieben hat -
dürfte das nicht hierhergelangen.
Wir haben mal
eine Untersuchung gemacht.
Diese ergab, dass 30 % der Geräte,
die exportiert wurden,
nicht funktionstüchtig waren.
Aber die Hälfte davon
konnte man reparieren.
Und diese hatten nachher
durchaus ein gutes Leben.
Und der Rest, die 15 %,
und das ist eben ein hohes Volumen,
also eine grosse Anzahl
von Elektroschrottgeräten
oder von Elektroschrott,
ist eigentlich illegal ins Land
gekommen, müsste man sagen.
Wir sind hier
in einem sog. Repair Shop.
Das Geschäftsmodell ist so,
dass sie versuchen,
die Geräte zu reparieren.
Sie nehmen vielleicht
aus alten Geräten,
die nicht mehr
funktionstüchtig sind,
ein Teil heraus,
um die Geräte so zusammenzubauen.
Thank you very much!
- Thank you!
Wenn man es
nicht mehr reparieren kann,
sieht man in dem Gerät
immer noch einen Wert:
Es gibt Metalle darin -
wie Kupfer oder Eisen.
In den Leiterplatten von Computern
sind Edelmetalle wie Gold enthalten.
Dann versucht man eben,
an diese Materialien zu kommen.
Dort fangen die Probleme an.
# Welcome to my world.
# Step right through the door.
Hier sind wir jetzt
auf dem Agbogbloshie Scrapyard,
dem Zentrum von Accra,
wo der ganze Schrott zusammenkommt,
wo alle Sammler von Elektroschrott
zusammenkommen,
aber man sieht hier
auch viele Autoteile.
Und hier sieht man die Kehrseite:
Alle Geräte
kommen ans Ende ihres Lebens.
Dann werden sie hier verarbeitet.
Da wird von Hand gearbeitet
und nicht darauf geachtet,
was ins Erdreich ausläuft usw.
Das sind natürlich Bedingungen,
die nicht sein sollten.
Hier sind ganz viele Leute,
die davon leben,
diese Sachen auseinanderzunehmen
und Rohmaterialien zurückzugewinnen.
Diese verkaufen sie dann wieder.
Sie sagen, er könne nicht reden
und nicht hören,
aber er hat hier seinen Job.
Er hat sich
auf diese Motoren spezialisiert
und nimmt sie auseinander.
Er gewinnt das Kupfer zurück.
Diese Kupferspule
ist ein paar Dollar wert.
Dann hat man die Leiterplatte
und die Kabel rundherum.
Das ist eigentlich der ganze Wert
eines
solchen Kathodenstrahlfernsehers.
Und dann gibt es Bleiglas.
Dieses Bleiglas ist nachher
eigentlich das grosse Problem -
wegen der Entsorgung.
Die Sammlerquote in diesen Ländern
ist viel höher
als diejenige in der Schweiz.
D.h., es wird wirklich fast alles
von diesem Abfall eingesammelt.
Kommt noch hinzu:
Es gibt viele arme Leute.
Das ist ganz typisch
für diese Länder.
Arme Leute findet man wirklich ...
Das Ende der Gesellschaft findet man
häufig auf diesen Abfallhalden.
Sie versuchen,
sich ein Leben zu machen,
indem sie den Abfall sortieren
und wertvolle Materialien
daraus entnehmen,
diese wieder verkaufen und so
am Schluss des Tages etwas haben,
womit sie sich
etwas zu essen kaufen können.
Das ist aus dem ganzen Apparat.
Das ist das einzige Teil,
das sie verkaufen können,
weil es einen Abnehmer
für dieses Plastik gibt.
Und der ganze Rest,
der hier auf dem Boden liegt,
geht auf einen Dumpsite.
Es wird auf einen grossen Haufen
geschmissen.
Damit passiert nichts.
Das ist natürlich schlecht.
Das ist das,
was unsere Projekte
auch ändern wollen, dass man sagt:
"Es gibt Entsorgungslösungen
für all diese Abfälle."
Also dass sie nicht
auf diesen Landfills oder Dumpsites
entsorgt werden müssen.
Let's move forward!
Als ich mit dieser Arbeit anfing
und mich damit auseinandersetzte,
hatte ich manchmal
schon schlaflose Nächte,
wenn ich an solchen Orten war,
denn wir sind uns das nicht gewohnt.
Dann sieht man Kinder, die
auf irgendeiner Dumpsite aufwachsen,
und denkt:
"Die haben im Leben
nie eine Chance!"
Und die Leute tun sich
gesundheitlich sozusagen viel an.
Ja, das Ganze ist ein Prozess.
Wir müssen uns bewusst sein:
Auch in Europa gingen wir
durch solche Sachen durch.
Ich denke,
da muss man auch das sehen.
Es ist ein Prozess.
Meine Vision ist,
dass hier auf dem Agbogbloshie
irgendwann
auch eine professionelle
Recyclinganlage steht.
* Sanfte Musik *
So machen sie Aluminimumtöpfe.
Hinter uns werden sie geschmolzen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist ein Produkt, das sinnvoll
ist und das sie hier herstellen.
Das kann man jetzt
sehr positiv werten -
mit all dem Negativen,
das wir gesehen haben.
Das sind auch wieder Sachen, auf
welche die Leute stolz sein können.
Dort hinten
sehen wir jetzt die Lagune
oder den Fluss -
oder was davon übrig bleibt.
Das ist eine Katastrophe.
Wenn wir ins Wasser blicken,
sehen wir einen Müllhaufen.
Das fliesst irgendwann ins Meer.
Das ist natürlich
eine Riesenschweinerei.
Bis man die Geräte
auseinandergenommen hat,
ist es nicht problematisch.
Aber sobald die Leute
das Kupfer zurückgewinnen wollen
und dann ein Kabel vorfinden -
"Da ist Plastik,
so kann ich es nicht verkaufen!" -,
verbrennen sie halt das Kabel,
bis das ganze Plastik verbrannt ist,
und können so
das Kupfer zurückgewinnen.
Der Rauch
ist sicher sehr, sehr schlecht.
Bei der Verbrennung
entstehen Dioxine.
Das ist etwas vom Giftigsten,
das man kennt.
Sie entstehen durch die Verbrennung
gewisser Chemikalien, die drin sind.
Mit Kupfer zusammen
kann Dioxin entstehen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Schlimmste von allem.
Theoretisch ist das in Ghana
tatsächlich verboten.
Man darf nicht einfach so
Dinge verbrennen.
Aber hier ist der Vollzug schwierig.
Würde man mit der Polizei kommen,
käme es zu grossen Unruhen,
denn davon
hängen mehrere Tausend Leute ab.
Das ist doch einigermassen heikel.
Also die Vision ist, dass
so ein Agbogbloshie bestehen bleibt,
aber auf eine nachhaltige Art,
also dass auf eine saubere Art
rezykliert wird.
Die Menschen sollen weiterhin
ihr tägliches Einkommen haben,
etwas verdienen und
eine gute Lebensgrundlage haben.
Es soll ihnen
auch sozial besser gehen.
Sie sollen Anschluss an Sozialhilfe,
Gesundheitshilfe usw. haben.
Das ist die Vision.
Und daher versucht unser Projekt,
an verschiedenen Enden zu arbeiten
und einen Beitrag zu leisten.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Wir gehen zu den Vollzugsbehörden
des Umweltministeriums.
Das ist unser Hauptpartner im
Projekt mit der Schweizer Regierung.
Wir haben heute eigentlich
das erste Steering Comittee,
also den Steuerungsausschuss,
des Projekts in Ghana.
In diesem Steuerungsausschuss
ist das Ministerium selbst dabei,
das Umweltministerium.
Dann ist das Ministerium für Finance
dabei.
Sie regeln die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen den Ländern.
Und die Schweizerische Botschaft
ist dabei.
Wir besprechen das Programm,
das wir für die ganzen vier Jahre
aufgestellt haben.
Das Wichtige ist auch,
dass man die Leute vor Ort
wirklich zu Experten macht,
denn irgendwann endet unser Projekt.
Dann sollten die Resultate
nachhaltig bleiben.
D.h., wir müssen hier
auch die Expertise aufbauen.
Da sind wir ganz zuversichtlich.
Wir haben in unserem Team
sehr gute Leute.
Das sind im Land
schon anerkannte Experten.
Okay, bye! Ciao!
Es kamen noch gute Inputs,
was man noch anders machen
bzw. verbessern könnte.
In dem Sinne habe ich das Gefühl,
dass alle zufrieden rausgingen.
Wir wissen auch,
wie wir weiterfahren müssen.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn man in solchen Projekten
arbeitet und auch sieht,
was deren Auswirkung
in anderen Ländern sein kann,
überlegt man sich selbst
natürlich auch,
wie man mit diesen Konsumgütern
umgeht.
An einem Black Friday
sollte man vielleicht überlegen:
"Muss man es wirklich kaufen,
nur weil es 100 Fr. billiger ist?"
Man hat dann immer das Gefühl,
man habe 100 Fr. gespart,
aber wenn man das Gerät
gar nicht braucht,
hat man vielleicht
zu viel Geld ausgegeben,
auch wenn es 100 Fr. billiger war.
Wir sagen ja immer:
"Das sind Entwicklungsländer."
Also "unterentwickelt"
sagt man im Prinzip nicht mehr,
aber das meint man damit.
Dann frage ich mich,
ob wir nicht
etwas überentwickelt sind.
Ich habe durchaus das Gefühl,
dass man, wenn man hierherkommt,
von diesen Leuten
auch etwas lernen kann.
Darum sagen wir
bei unseren Projekten:
Es ist ein Austausch.
Es ist ein sog. Knowledge Exchange.
D.h., wir wollen auch von hier
etwas lernen.
Sie können von uns etwas lernen.
Dann müssen wir uns
in der Mitte treffen,
um die idealen Lösungen zu finden.
Aber ich nehme auch durchaus
etwas mit nach Hause und sage:
"Es ist wahnsinnig,
was die können und machen."
"Warum machen wir das nicht?"
* Sanfte Popmusik *
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2019